what sits right behind Joe Biden is even
scary it's Kamala Harris you might
remember this one
and most recent
ly
gender ideology
well so
what are we talking about here
classes that teach women's history
women's equality
the study of the fact that there are
still only 25 women in the United States
Senate in a body of 100
it's just something else first off
gender ideology has nothing to do with
women's history women's history like say
American history or black history or
whatever history history the facts
behind history aren't just that they're
facts so no one's saying don't teach the
history of women in America the right to
vote the right to work
etc etc that is very different it has
absolutely nothing to do with gender
ideology and I would say she either
knows that but I don't know if she knows
that so she either knows it or doesn't
know it it's almost irrelevant at this
point but these are just not the best
and the brightest right
[Music]
foreign